all right many immigrants say they're
fleeing to the US because of relentless
gang violence in their homeland last
year nearly 30% of unaccompanied minors
who entered the US illegally came from
El Salvador the Central American country
has one of the world's highest murder
rates Omar Villafranca is in El
Salvador's capital since Salvador where
police showed him how gangs are
terrorizing neighborhoods
Omar good morning good morning
local police tell us one of the biggest
problems here in El Salvador is gang
violence and we talked to people who
told us they're willing to risk
everything just to get to the u.s.
border
we got a first-hand look at everything
that they are trying to escape as
darkness fell in El Salvador we wrote
along with heavily armed police hunting
for members of the notorious ms-13 and
body of a teen gangs while we were
driving around officers immediately
stopped their trucks and confronted
these three men and they think they are
ms-13 they're pretty sure based on what
they're wearing especially shoes shoes
here good shoes Nike shoes can be
expensive these guys are wearing them
the police are out day and night
sweeping neighborhoods paralyzed by gang
violence we were with them as they
arrested this man who they say is a
member of ms-13 short for me - Alvis
lucha
it is murder but he tells us he is not
with ms-13 his amigos and mother no do
you have friends in ms-13 we asked no he
told us between 60,000 and 100,000
Salvadorians are thought to be involved
with gangs and the evidence of the gangs
are everywhere we're walking here in
this neighborhood and we found an area
where body o18 has basically put a mural
up of everybody who died it says in
memory of the homies got their names and
gravestones with all their nicknames on
there
earlier in the day police took us to San
martín a neighborhood they say is gang
control these houses were once filled
with families the many have now fled
some of them for the US border Jose
Rubio lives in Los Angeles but was
deported to El Salvador in 1994 ie the
country needs jobs he says so people
don't have to get involved in gangs but
this woman says the games here even
extort businesses and they find ways to
force young people to join know how I
don't need anymore
the gangs grab that she says and they
join out of fear they will be killed
temporary protected status for El
Salvadorian immigrants in the u.s. ends
in September of 2019 and that means they
may be forced out of the US and there's
an estimated 200,000 el Salvadorians
living and working in the US and they're
sending part of their paycheck here back
home and a lot of people worried that if
that money stops coming home the
situation here could get even worse
Gayle Omar Villafranca reporting from El
Salvador really glad he's right I don't
think most people realize how bad it is
and we have hearing that over and over
again they it's worth risking your life
to get out of that place mhm thank you
very much Omar